I have a radical idea before we start in on The Deleuze.
Let's just say out loud what sections of the book we are looking at and what book it
is that does that.
What do you mean?
Just say like, hey, we're, we're reading The Logic of Sense.
And this week we focused on Series 16, 17, and 18.
Okay.
Yeah.
That in listening to the, uh, you realize like it, well, much of our Hegel conversation
isn't about Hegel.
So it doesn't matter what the section is.
Well, it does.
And it does.
I mean, I don't think it really matters.
I think it's a pretty minor thing, but you know, like sometimes somebody might, like we're
making this reference to what, right?
We know Hegel roughly and you know, likely, you know, we're likely talking about the Phenomenology
of Spirit and we reference numbers.
And I think just be good.
Like, hey, you know, one way of engaging this is just not to care about the specificity of
the Hegel at all.
Another way might be to be like, hey, I'm going to go read this stuff and then come and see
how things reactivate.
So at least giving people the opportunity.
I totally agree.
I had a similar thought.
I didn't, it didn't stay with me, but I had a similar thought in listening to the things
of like, it certainly could be helpful to just say, hey, Phenomenology of Spirit, like
pages, whatever to whatever, or I mean, you know, so you're right.
You're right.
So Logic of Sense, Series 16, 17, and 18 for, for today.
That was the last time we were supposed to do 15, 16, and 17 and we only did 15.
I still, okay.
So if we're, if we're jumping into The Logic of Sense, I still, I find seven, 17 is one
of my favorite series.
Uh, the actually, as I said before, like the next couple, 17, 18, 19 are like my favorites
in the book.
Um, 17 or do you mean 18?
The 18, I'm sorry.
The Three Images of Philosophers.
So 18, 19, 20, whatever.
The next chunk is like a really great chunk.
Like I'm really looking forward to it.
And we included the last one here and I find it so easy to think with so easy to talk about.
And yet I just had this naggy feeling, and again, after rereading 16 and 17, that they're
crucial, right?
Like the, the, the, the ontological Genesis and the, and the logical Genesis, like that
the, the question, and I, and I just don't have my head around them.
I mean, even, even close, like I just have a very, very hard time.
And I feel like this is one of those cases where I feel like I probably need to take a
class, you know, like not just, not just me sitting and reading.
More, that's not going to solve the problem that I need a class.
Like I actually, uh, ordered two, uh, uh, books on Logic of Sense.
Cause that's the sort of equivalent of sometimes it's the equivalent of taking a class.
So I'm going to like do some secondary stuff on it.
Cause it just, I just had this sense that those two chapters really matter.
And I don't really, I can't do very much with them.
I mean, I, I don't have much to say, or it doesn't, I don't think with them.
They don't, they're not provocative because I just, I'm not in, you know, I don't have
a hook.
Well, there are so many technical, technical chapters, right?
Those two series.
I mean, I, yeah, I found myself in a similar situation, but then kind of just sampling.
I mean, this is maybe a problem with the way I read in general or just my style of reading,
but I'll just latch onto like a sentence or two and be like, well, that kind of works for
me, but in terms of a comprehensive understanding of these two chapters or series, I mean, I'm,
I'm with you.
I'm like, I don't know how they're supposed to, I can't even give you really an idea of
the relationship between the ontological and the logical, like any kind of like summary
or thesis statement.
Um, at this point.
I mean, I have a sense of that.
Like I, I, I have a very vague sense of what he's trying to do in 16 and 17 and it's ontology
and epistemology.
I mean, I think that would be the simplest way of breaking, breaking it down.
Um, and the, and the insistence on the, um, the neutral quality or static, right.
Quality that is also genetic, right.
That is also, so in other words, he just in the previous chapters insisted on the point
that sense is not causal, right.
It is, it is an effect, uh, of bodies.
Um, and if it's causal, it's quasi causal in relationship to other sense.
Right.
And so that's, so that's the transcendent, the sort of transcendent layer in which he
wants to work.
Um, now I think he wants to say, well, it is kind of causal, right.
It's, it's causal in the sense that it's genetic and it's genetic of bodies.
It's going to be, so in other words, the arrow is going to kind of go back in the other direction,
but it's not, he doesn't want to use the terminology of causality.
And, and again, I'm not entirely clear on why other than this vague sense that what he's
trying to do with transcendence here is to make not transcendence imminence, but to kind
of flip the whole problem.
And I'm not exactly sure what that means, right.
I don't have, uh, um, the base.
Frankly, I actually feel like the basis that I'm lacking is an analytic philosophy here.
Like I really feel like, you know, distinguishing between the analytic value and the synthetic
value of the proposition.
For example, that's one example of a distinction that matters to him here.
That is an anal, what we call analytic philosophical distinction.
It's not a distinction that you take up or you find anywhere in kind of continental philosophy,
You know?
Well, this is so predicated on Leibniz and his theory of the monad and, and compulsibility.
Yeah.
See, it may be.
And I just don't know.
I don't know Leibniz at all.
Like at all.
No.
I mean, my, like, I, I spent a couple of weeks reading him in an undergraduate class
on modern, early modern philosophy.
So, you know, my, my understanding, I, I, I have a vague intuitive sense of it, but like,
I mean, I started reading around it today.
I was just reading some stuff on Plato.Stanford today on, on, because I, I, you know, I recognize
the stuff of the, you know, Adam as sinner and compulsibility as Leibniz.
And it just helped to kind of read around that a little bit.
By the way, just as a, just as an interjection on the Stanford question, because this is something,
it's a resource that I go to all of the time and I never find it helpful.
Like I, I have never found it.
Like I, it allows me, there's this weird way in which it provides plenty of background,
but it never solves the thing that I went to the Stanford Encyclopedia of Philosophy
for.
I find it to be very conservative.
Maybe that's, maybe that's what it is.
But then also like, I mean, yeah, I honestly, I find Wikipedia to be more helpful for these
kinds of things.
Yeah, I agree.
I agree.
Yeah.
Because I'm not looking for a claim or an argument.
I'm just, I just know that there's a couple little pieces of very generic context that will
help snap some things into place for me.
And that's what's missing from Stanford.
Stanford, I feel like, at least in terms of the many times that I, because I go to it
all of the time looking for stuff and I just, I'm always like, well, I understand that.
I understand the distinctions.
It's not like it's confusing, but it doesn't help me.
It doesn't, it never contextualizes things to give me a sense of, you know, why that distinction
matters or what the implications of it are.
It just explains.
Well, the other thing is, I think a lot of the Stanford, they're, they're authored, right?
And, you know, I think that if they, they, their authorship, I mean, I mean, like the function
that those publications would play on a CV just don't carry as much weight if they served,
you know, the all too basic function of Wikipedia.
So in some ways, actually the fact that you get, I mean, they're written by people who,
you know, have quite a bit of expertise in these very specific areas.
Sure, sure.
You know, something maybe about the slightly more democratic way in which Wikipedia is like
okay being very baseline and very, you know, and, and, and isn't trying, you know, Wikipedia
articles very rarely try to make points, but, but that, that was just an interjection, but
So, so did you find the Leibniz helpful in terms of, yeah, I mean, because, I mean, especially
when he was talking about, you know, it always threw me, I never could try, I could never
quite figure out how, you know, for Leibniz they're like a, the world is made of an infinite
set of monads and, I mean, unless if I thought about it at a level of atomism, right, and
it's usually compared to a sense of atomism or like, you know, the Cartesian corpuscle,
corpuscle or whatever, and like, all right, these are sort of, you know, just generic bits
that then make up other things, then I can understand that.
But for Leibniz, one, each monad is unique, and two, each monad reflects the world.
And, or, like, and I, I, that was always very, very difficult for me to understand until you
start thinking about it in Deleuze's relational senses, like, well, you know, each, this is
at the top of, of 110, and I think this is when he first brings up Leibniz, Leibniz was
then right to say that the individual monad expresses a world according to the relations
of other bodies with its own, as much as it expresses this relation according to the relation
of the parts of its own body.
In other words, like, the monad is caught up in a relationship with a bunch of other monads,
and the specific difference that is, that gets sort of unified or gets sort of compressed
in that set of relations is then reflected in the monad.
So it's not a, it is a reflection or an expression, but not representational.
It is, it is like that, that, that language of the mirror doesn't work if it's just sort
of like, it's not an objective expression, it is a subjective expression, or like, I mean,
it is through the filter of that monad as it is particularly situated within this set
of relations.
If you move that monad to a different sort of, like, set of coordinates, then it would
express a different world.
So expression means translation in, in the term, it doesn't mean expression in the sense
of just allowing it out, it means expression in the sense of changing it from one milieu to
another milieu.
Right.
Yeah, or, or a set of relations is expressed through a specific point.
In that set of relations.
Yeah.
Right.
Well, yeah, expression as opposed to the set of relations as a totality being represented
as a totality in some other medium.
It's not translation in that sense.
So the monad does not precede its relation to other monads or to the world, right?
The monad is a, is a product or an effect of its relationship, right?
It's not.
See, I'm, so I'm not as comfortable saying that because I think for, for, um, Leibniz,
like monads are the basic elements of the world, but it wouldn't make sense to think about,
but I, I still think it wouldn't make sense to think about a monad independent of its
relations, right?
So, so like I, I, maybe you could say something like this and no, I'm going out on a limb
here.
You could say that monads exist independent of a relationships, but they would never express
a world because they have no, there's nothing, they have, they have no relationality to something
else.
They have no, there's, there's no world to be expressed because a world is always has to
be at the particular configuration or like Deleuze uses the language of like the singularity
that is sort of draped over a series of ordinary points.
It's like, you have to create the surface and a point is not a surface.
So then Deleuze's intervention is basically that it's to expand that a little bit.
So while Leibniz kind of relies on some version of atomism, Deleuze's kind of critique or intervention
would be to say that, no, that it's relational at the bottom.
Like there's no, there's no singular unit.
So even the monad, it's even more relational than Leibniz is willing to admit.
Is that kind of his, if you see the monad as a singularity, but then again, like, I mean,
there was a certain unity to a singular, I mean, it wouldn't be a singularity, right?
Like monad is really just another name for the singularity.
Yeah.
A singularity without individuation.
Right.
Yeah.
These are pre-individual singularities, pre-individual monads that, I mean, to me, the intervention,
Deleuze's intervention into Spinoza, or into, I'm sorry, Leibniz, is that Leibniz can't think change
and evolution and movement in a system.
He can think, like, he can think about the expression of worlds and he can think about
the expression of, like, and a world for Leibniz is the totalized set of composable bodies,
right?
In other words, like, like a world is the total set of bodies that can exist in a relationship
with each other without contradiction.
And, you know, when Deleuze is talking about the divergence of a series that would create
incompossible worlds, like where, you know, the elements from one world are incompatible
with the elements of another, of another world.
Right.
Um, so, uh, uh, Leibniz can think the, like both the, um, the infinity of a world and the
infinity of worlds, right?
And this is where he gets, I mean, Leibniz becomes theological and, and imagines our world
as the best of all possible worlds, uh, given like the presumption of the, you know, omnipotent,
omniscient, um, you know, all the omni aspect, predicates of God.
But, you know, um, Leibniz theory of change and Leibniz theory of, of, um, of motion and
movement is, I mean, I think pretty clunky.
It's, it's like a pre determined harmony or preset harmony where every monad as the expression
of a world has its own predestined path, which makes sense.
If you think of a, of a singularity sort of expressing a world, then like the entire world
is expressed in its totality, right?
So, you know, that would just be every moment, temporally, every moment is sort of laid out,
but you also have an infinite number of, of monads.
And for like, there has to be a pre-established harmony that's like, all right, the sort of
unfolding of this one and the unfolding of that one, they just, like you were requires the
deus ex machina of, you know, like the God that started the clock all at the same time.
And Deleuze's critique of, of Leibniz and so far as there's a critique here is that it's
because he doesn't think about the divergent syntheses that link, um, uh, incompossible
worlds.
And that's why he's so fixated on the Adam who has not sinned and the Adam who has sinned
as like, that there is a more general version of Adam that in general is not the right word
there, but I can add in that sort of, um, disjunctively connects those two worlds that
there are, there are passageways or there are, um, communications relays between these
worlds.
And it is those relays.
It's the difference, the differential relays between those worlds that are those a layer
laitory moments of chance that, you know, it depends on how those two worlds get connected.
And now like that's evolution, that is an introduction of an evolutionary movement within the otherwise
static, um, uh, a theory of, of, um, of individual and world for Leibniz because he sets out the
problem right on the first page.
It's like this entire seven 16 is just like, look, how do we think the relationship between
singularities, individuals and worlds, right?
And, um, and, and, and it's like, well, Leibniz gives us the baseline, but it doesn't move.
And this is how you make it move.
Right.
Yeah.
I mean, so I need to, I mean, that's Leibniz has been one, you know, another, another thing
pushing me in that direction is you guys know Dan Smith, the Duluth scholars up at Purdue.
Um, I've always found his writing to be really smart and interesting.
And I, I, I always learned from it and he wrote a book on Leibniz and I just avoided it.
Um, because Leibniz to me was this figure that like, I have no purchase on and no understanding
of.
And, and so I was just like, well, I'm just going to leave that thing out.
But now I'm feeling like, fuck, I got to not leave that out.
Deleuze turns to Leibniz all the time.
Yeah.
I, I know, I know.
But I was like, uh, I could just skip that.
I felt that way about Spinoza until about 20 years ago, like 20 years ago.
I'm like, okay, I just can't skip this.
But when, when Dan and I taught this to Lucy Guattari class and he convinced me in the midst
of that class, he's like, no, no, no, you got to read Spinoza.
And then I was feeling the pull, but afterwards I was like, yeah, I do have to read Spinoza.
And now it's like, oh my gosh, how could I possibly have been reading this and attempting
to make sense of it without Spinoza?
You know?
It, it feels a little bit like here, like, so there's a couple or couplet in these two
series, 16 and 17, where he prefers Leibniz, but he also treats Husserl, right?
A decent amount.
And I know that they're...
He smacks Husserl down, yeah.
I know.
He really, but it feels like the critique, again, if there is a critique of Leibniz, it
feels like it follows a similar logic to the critique of Husserl, where that's like, there's
an internalized logic of predication, right?
Which he's attacking, but it feels like he's attacking that in both figures.
It's just more viciously with Husserl.
Like there's the hierarchy of the phenomenological system in Husserl, which is very sort of, it's
unexamined and it's not as rigorous as Deleuze is.
But it also feels, I mean, what we were just talking about, it's like with the monad and
then the kind of hierarchical organization of life, it feels like it's a similar intervention
into both figures or into both philosophies, even though he clearly is shitting on Husserl
more.
Well, this is on 113.
To understand this operation, we must always return to the theater of Leibniz and not the
cumbersome machinery of Husserl.
So that's, you know, this is right after an extended discussion of Husserl.
So, yeah.
Yeah.
Well, I mean, Husserl, and then you could obviously, you could put in Hegel there probably as well.
You know, the cumbersome machinery of Hegel.
You know, he would be clearly intervening into that.
And although Leibniz did not attain the free character of the play since he neither wanted
nor how to breathe enough chance into it or to make of divergence an object of affirmation
as such, he nevertheless ascended a lot of consequence at the level of the actualization,
which is what's preoccupying us at this point.
Yeah.
I mean, my note there is, you know, Leibniz couldn't make his world move and evolve, which,
you know, he couldn't see divergence as the aleatory moment of the expression of difference.
And the other, you just read that line, although Leibniz did not attain the free character of
this play, that immediately made me think of Deleuze's Kant book and his analysis of the faculty
of imagination, which is that, you know, Kant expends so much energy and effort to try to
cordon off the proper domains of the imagination, but he can't because he constantly is sort of
like running into the way that the operation of the imagination actually undergirds the supposedly
more serious operations of the understanding and reason.
And like, you know, Kant tries to contain that and just like, no, that's the engine that
makes everything else possible.
Right.
And maybe this is an obvious point, but my thing was just like, at the most, at the really
general register, the critique is at least similar, where it's like, there's not enough
contingency in this system, right?
Like for Leibniz, that's the basic critique.
Like he went this far, he almost got to this theory, but he wasn't willing to insert chance
or contingency.
And then for Husserl or Husserl, it's the same thing, but maybe a more, you know, blatant
or flagrant, you know, containment of contingency.
You know what I'm saying?
My understanding of his critique of Husserl is that Husserl, one, allows common and good
sense to predefine the phenomenological world.
That's, that's my take too, yeah.
Right.
Yeah.
That part.
Which is a containment of chance and relationality and contingency, right?
I mean, it's like he's, he's reifying all of these terms within the system and not, you
know, treating how the, how they came about, right?
It's like all the terms are kind of given and uninterrogated.
I mean, I will say, you know, one of the things I'm trying to think through is this more general
sense of Adam that acts as a communicating figure between these incompossible worlds.
And he'll use the language of, he very hesitantly uses the language of generality.
And it's always sandwiched in between things like, and you can absolutely no way think that
generality exists, but that he uses that word.
But it gets me thinking about our conversation last time about transcendence and the way that
he uses transcendence.
And for me, like this, this section puts that one, like, I just cannot think transcendence
vertically anymore after, you know, like the very first sentence on 109, you know, series
16, this surface topology, these impersonal and pre-individual nomadic singularities, or
he's going to use the Leibniz monad in there, constitute the real transcendental field.
The transcendental field is a surface topology of impersonal and pre-individual nomadic singularities.
Like, boom, done.
Like, and then transcendence is, is like, I mean, the trains of transition, like, I mean,
the moving across of the surface of the active work of connecting this surface point to this
surface point to this, and that itinerative movement is remaking the world, which I think
is going to get into section 18 and the three images of the philosopher, like, I, I've read
that, you know, we read that eight years ago, John, and I liked it then, but I, I've read
it like probably two or three times since then.
And this is the first time where I felt like I just, it just totally clicked with me, where
I always understood the heights, I always understood the depth, and I kind of wrapped my head around
the surface, and I feel like I clicked this time.
Yeah.
I, I also feel like there's a, there's a lot of, like, um, cause when does he start using
the, the language of desire?
Is it not until Anti-Oedipus or, uh, A Thousand Plateaus or something?
Um.
Anti-Oedipus is where it's huge.
Because, yeah, it feels like the seed of that precise formulation of desire and desiring
machines is in this, uh, section as well in 16.
Like I just noted at the, towards the end of, uh, 110 in that, uh, second, second to last
paragraph, he goes, to be actualized or to actualize oneself means to extend over a series
of ordinary points, to be selected according to a rules of, uh, of convergence, to be incarnated
in a body, to become the state of a body, and to be renewed, renewed locally for the sake
of limited new actualizations and extensions.
Not one of these characteristics belongs to singularities as such.
All right.
So it just reminded me of, like, his very precise articulation of subjectivity under the moniker
of desire, you know?
And, and this, this just felt like, not, not that it's like a, a less developed version,
it just felt like the seed of that definition of, of his version of desire, you know?
Well, and at least in this book in general, he's less antagonistic to, uh, psychoanalysis,
right?
Like this is pre the Guattari impact.
So, um, so, I mean, that would make sense in that regard.
I mean, I mean, I'm interested in hearing Nathaniel's clicking.
Like, if it, if it, if it clicks for you, man, explain it.
Yeah.
Like, explain what clicked in terms of that.
Because I'd love to continue to, I mean, 17, or 16 and 17 are, are just more difficult
for me.
So I would love to spend time with them.
But, yeah, I mean, I can give you my take on, uh, 18 quickly.
I mean, because it's a similar, it's a similar, right.
It's a similar dynamic that he's after.
He just kind of plays it out in that notion of the geography of, of thinking, you know, which
by the way, that alone is an interesting idea.
The thinking has a geography and an implicit geography.
Well, and not even just that it has a geography, but that it has a geography before having a history
that it traces dimensions before constructing systems, right.
That, that like these, the, these philosophical interventions are carving the space for the
possibility of differentiating them before they get differentiated and marked up.
So, and, and, you know, so I take, I take that to be a kind of jab at Hegel, right.
Like the, uh, the notion of a prehistorical geography is, you know, like this is prior to the
Phenomenology, which is entirely historical, you know?
Yeah.
I hear that.
But I mean, uh, so the transcendence of the, the, the heights of, of Plato makes sense.
You know, the, the surface is, is the realm of the phenomenon and one and, and of impure mixtures
and only by sort of purifying those mixtures and discovering their, the, the, the heights of their
source, um, that, you know, this, this is the, an anecdote to the suffering of, of life on, at the
level of the surface.
And I really liked the way that he attributes that mania is the specific disease of, of
Platonic heights.
I love this.
I mean, I read this over this, this section over the summer, um, for, for my Phaedrus piece.
And I really want to turn this in the exact opposite direction because I know that, you
know, Deleuze is taking a jab at Plato here, but I wanted, my project, I think I've decided
for the Phaedrus piece is to imagine platonic madness traversing the surface.
Like how interesting does platonic madness come when you're not even trying to make it
leave the ground, but it is, you know, as I'll, I'll get to later here, only making connections
between, um, propositions and, um, uh, whatever, I'll, I'll find it here later.
Um, but yeah, so I'm just going to repeat this section because I love it so much.
We are not going to compare philosophies and diseases, except for I'm going to right now,
but there are properly philosophical diseases.
Idealism is the illness congenital to the Platonic, congenital to the Platonic philosophy.
And with its litany of ascents and downfalls, uh, it is even philosophy's manic depressive
form.
Mania inspires and guides Plato.
Dialectics is the flight of ideas.
The idea fluked as Plato says of the idea, it flees or it perishes.
And even in the death of Socrates, there is a trace of, of depressive suicide.
And then he turns to Nietzsche as the sort of like the, the one who rediscovers the depths
of the pre-Socratics.
And it's like, no, the, the surface is phenomenon.
So you need to get below the surface to understand the conditions of possibility that lead to these
phenomenons.
And by the way, the further you dig, you're always going to find a different set of subterranean,
you know, caverns or substructures that support the, the, the higher, uh, uh, layer.
Right.
But that's where to me, that's where to me, the, the, the depth model of the caves, always
behind caves starts to become a surface, right?
Like, so at, at, at a certain point, the, the going deeper, this is where Nietzsche is an
interesting hinge figure insofar as he does on the one hand, rediscover the pre-Socratic
depth as opposed to the transcendence of, of Plato and idealism.
But on the other hand, he also is the engine for making that depth, no longer a depth and
no longer getting behind.
And that's the, the masks.
He doesn't talk about it in terms of masks here, but that's the, that's the, the idea to
me is the mask or the cave behind a cave, the perpetuation of caves behind caves is the
thing that leads you to go, Oh wait, this was all on the surface.
Anyway, there was never a cave behind a cave, right?
Like it never, it didn't actually keep going in that infinite regress sense.
It's the point at which you, so he also is the guy who says, you know, the Greeks were
great because they were superficial.
So he's, he, he restores this privilege of the surface in addition to discovering the
notion of depth.
Right.
Well, I mean, because as soon as the, the movement of the depth becomes just a constant
movement that you never, like once you give up the idea of finding the foundation, then
it's not a depth anymore.
Then it's not a depth, but I would say the same thing for Platonic mania.
I mean, I, I, the, just this line, it, it flees or it perishes.
It's in constant movement.
It is perpetually ascending or ascending and descending, or it's gone.
There's no stability there.
And like, I think of the myth of the charioteer in the Phaedrus and, you know, the description
of, you know, that, which is what it really is.
And, you know, all of the descriptions of what you would take to be the Platonic forms,
they are, there was nothing static or stable about them at all.
Like, I mean, it's a frigging circus up there.
You've got, you know, these things that have no form, no color, no shape, no whatever that
are only provoking the movements of the gods around them.
I mean, it is literally a procession, right?
Yeah.
But the fact of it simply being movement isn't, I don't think, because it's, it's always movement
up.
And, and so that, that's the problem is that we have to know what truth is before we can
actually assess, you know, any particular truth.
We have to know what knowledge is or virtue is before essentially, you know, like, you're
never going to get there.
Well, but so in other words, if you do the same move that I just did with Nietzsche's
caves, if you do that with Plato, then Plato can be the guy who, again, like if you push
transcendence to an extreme, it, it relocates itself.
Like if you push depth to an extreme, you know, or, or you make it infinite, uh, or, or, or
deferred, right?
At some point, both moves end up reorienting themselves on this level.
And then it becomes, I mean, then the distinction becomes, I don't know what a question of style,
right?
Like it doesn't become a distinct illness in that sense, you know, or a manic style of
Becoming or a schizophrenic style of becoming, right?
Right.
I mean, it's interesting.
He doesn't attribute a disease though, to Heracles.
I don't, I don't remember one.
Is there one?
Oh, to Hercules, the Hercules thing.
Yeah.
It must be leprosy, the skin of, a disease of the skin.
He's the, uh, well, so Empedocles, Empedocles is the figure for Aetna.
That's the depth.
Yeah.
The lead sandal.
Right.
And so, and then the surface, we got Diogenes is one, um, and Hercules.
Yeah.
But there's not, but there's not a philosophical disease associated with the surface.
No, he, he just wears the lion's, uh.
Yeah.
Again, because he's hiding his leprosy.
That's gotta be, that's gotta be the answer.
Eczema.
Eczema is the.
So it would be interesting because, I mean, affect them, what you're, what you would end
up saying is that, um, that like Plato's dialectical method is the stick, right?
Is Diogenes' stick.
That is only ever provoking.
Right.
And the mistake is thinking that it's functionally transcending the conditions of it.
It's like, it's no different than that stick or the fish or whatever other, you know, the
Diogenes kinds of stories that Plato is effectively doing the same thing.
Although, I mean, it's hard because it's, it just seems to me to, you know, Plato still
relies on a notion of continuity of the logic, you know, whereas Diogenes is, is, there's
a parataxis to the Diogenes actions.
I mean, he doesn't use the word parataxis, but it, but it's, it's like the, the, um, the
non-connection between the question, what is virtue and me throwing a fish at you, right?
Like the, the, that's the thing that he likes about Diogenes is that there's not a parallel.
Whereas if you say, what is virtue to Plato, there's going to be a connection, right?
There's going to be a recognizable connection between the response of say Socrates, right?
Well, there's this, there's this section in the Phaedrus that I'm going to make a big deal
of that.
It shocks me to no end that, that, um, Derrida does not really attend to it at all in, in Plato's
Pharmacy, where this is toward the end.
And he's talking about writing as a form of just, you know, like it's just play, right?
That, you know, when, when is writing okay?
Well, it's just okay when it's someone who is just sort of doing it for their own amusement.
And then he references back to his speeches and he's like, like, you know, like, look at
the speeches that we composed.
They were amusing.
They were a series of, of plays sort of provoked out of this, you know, kind of competitive
Dissoi Logoi with, with, um, um, right.
And he's like, and maybe there was some element of truth to them.
Maybe not.
But, you know, if nothing else, it was like, it, it provoked this, this, you know, like,
uh, um, provoke this movement of thought that started connecting a whole bunch of things
that now is now sudden, like, you know, you go from the virtues of the non lover to winged
horses to rhetoric to, I mean, like that is a pretty paratactical movement.
If you ask me, but I mean, I, but it, but it seems like the role of the demon will be
very important there because I think the usual reading would be, it is the date Damon's intervention,
which transitions it from playful, you know, like provocation land, agonism land to truth
land, right?
Like after the, the demon who, who gives him his conscience, right?
He's like, I've sinned against love.
I mean, I haven't read it in a while, but I've sinned against love.
And it's, if he were referring to Lysias's speech and Socrates' first speech, I would agree
with you, but it seems pretty clear to me that he's at least also including his, his atonement
speech in there and perhaps even more, I mean, because that's the one that is so mythologically,
you know, bonkers, right?
That seems to me that he's including that in there.
And the other, like, you know, think about the reason that the Phaedrus is considered
to be bad dialogue.
Well, that's good, by the way, if you could, but, but, but that's a good point.
Like if you can say that the reference to our speeches or whatever, isn't just the, the
playful pre-daemon intervention, pre-conscious intervention moments, it is also, then, then
I think that changes everything.
I think that you have good purchase there of like, yeah, in fact, this whole theory of
souls, right?
That, that engineered everything, you know, to, to come, right.
That, that it is part and parcel.
And look, I also do think that one can say it would be a problem to hypostasize the daemon
moment, uh, as, as the crucial one, as the determining change, even on Plato's terms, right?
That, um, so.
Because what you get in, because what, what you get with Socrates is like soccer, you know,
you could say that the daemon takes over Socrates and tells him no.
That in a chance sense of, but he's also taken over by the nymphs, the muses, he's sort of
taken over by the, he mentions like, oh, I've heard better stories than Lysias's, you know,
like I heard him from Sappho and someone else, I can't pronounce his name.
It's like, he's taken over by fragments of other writings.
And he's so like the side of Socrates is constantly the side of sort of being momentarily taken over
by this, which then leads to another takeover like this and another takeover like this.
And you know, I don't buy, like that still happens after the daemon, right?
And, and you know, the, and that moment of the daemon as well, that, that leads into the
second speech, that would be the move to complete that dialogue.
You finish the atonement.
Why does he stay?
He wanted to leave.
He couldn't because he needed to atone.
He got taken over by another spirit.
He tries to atone.
Then why don't you leave then?
But they're like, no, now we're going to talk like, then it's the myth of the cicadas.
And it's about like, just, it's not the necessity to complete anything.
It's the necessity to just keep talking and thinking.
What do you mean?
Why does he stay after the second speech?
Yeah.
He wanted to, he wanted to peace out, right?
He wanted to go back home.
He's out of his element.
So he did the job.
He atoned for the thing.
His sins are forgiven.
He didn't go blind.
So why does he stay?
Like, and part of the reason that the Phaedrus is criticized as, you know, a poorly composed
speech is that it seems to be disjointed between the two halves.
Like there's the stuff on love and the souls.
And then there's the stuff on rhetoric and writing.
And what do they have to do with each other?
And, you know, Derrida does a pretty good job of giving a pretty good reason why they're
connected.
But, you know, part of it is because there's the inspiration of the cicadas that, I mean,
there's a paratactical movement between why do we have to stay here?
Because otherwise we'd be just like lazy and, you know, just trying to alleviate the suffering
of life.
But instead we're going to sort of like, we're going to think in response to the suffering
We're going to find the more noble pleasures of like thinking and philosophizing is just
the more noble pleasure than the pleasure of the slave, which is just removing the pain
of hunger, removing the pain of whatever else.
Stuff that tries to rehabilitate Plato or try to like make him just not the simple foil of
philosophy, like contemporary philosophy or contemporary rhetorical theory is it's like they make the
quasi intentional move that Derrida makes.
It's like kind of in spite of what Plato is trying to do, his text is doing this other thing.
Right.
And I want to try to remove even that little bit of intentionality and like, I'm not even
going to address what I think Plato was trying to do here.
I'm just going to offer a reading of the movement of the text and one way it gets activated,
one way that, that, you know, these, you know, yeah.
And so, yeah.
It just so happens to like make a platonic dialogue do something that is just completely antithetical
to the way that Plato typically gets read.
So your analysis would be very clearly just as much about styles of reading and interpretation
as it is about Plato.
You know, it's, it's about how, what choices you make as an interpreter, you know, and what
they do for the text or for the readers.
You know, it's like, it reminds me because I was, I redid or I re-listened to episode two
of the Hegel tapes.
And I don't want to get into broad.
This just reminds me of that because John, you were talking about different versions of
Barad that I could, or that anyone could deploy and that you don't have to make, you don't
necessarily have to make the critical intervention.
You can reveal or disclose how her text makes the moves that I'm kind of critiquing her for
not doing it.
So you can, you can make those choices as a reader and a writer.
It's not, and it's not dependent on the text in itself, having those moments or revealing
those moments, you know?
So it's, I don't know.
It's an interesting, it's an interesting question in itself.
What happens when you do that and what will happen the next step for Nathaniel in that
is when Plato becomes a figure for contingency, what is contingency, you know, like, what's
the, but that's where it gets interesting, right?
Like to me is what's the point of contingency then?
Like contingency has only ever done its work, uh, because it required some notion of transcendence
or, or what we would at least call non-contingency.
And if like, if, if it's all surface and if thinking has always been all surface, then that's
to me, again, that's where I come back to style, right?
Like the, the, the differences among them are not differences of disposition in some broad,
you know, uh, ontological sense.
Well, so this is what, they're just.
To bring it back to Deleuze, this is what clicked for me with series 18 that, I mean, one of
the things that I had a hard time wrapping my head around is why Hercules is, is the figure
of, of the surface.
Yeah.
Well, good.
Tell me, tell us that because I don't know the answer to that either.
And like the, I mean, the most direct reason is like he, he ascends to the heavens and
he pulls the heavens back down to the surface and he descends to the depths and he grabs
Cerberus and pulls them up to the surface.
Right.
And like that, that I got, but I just, but I didn't get what the surface was doing.
And then it sort of dawned on me that like Hercules is itinerant, right?
His 12 labors or 10 labors or whatever it was, he's, he travels all over, you know, the
Mediterranean world.
And, you know, his itinerary is linking this position in this past to this position in this
past.
And the style of the movement, the way in which these surface points get connected now
constitute worlds, right?
That's good.
I mean, to think about the interjection of contingency here, if the labors were in a different
order or if they were like different labors, different locations or whatever else, like
the world would get remade differently, that, that it is, it comes down, you know, not just
to like what points are connected, getting connected to what points, but the style in which, you
know, those connections are happening, the style of the movement between this point to that
point.
And it's, it's so weird.
I agree with that.
Go ahead.
Sorry.
I was just going to say, that's what, you know, toward the end of 18, and I feel like
Deleuze opens up this possibility where he talks about, you know, in a parallel manner,
Platonism undergoes a similar total reorientation.
And he's talking about, you know, the surface is no less explorable and unknown than depth
and height, which are nonsense.
I mean, like, it seems to me that we have to take seriously the bringing of the depth
to the surface and the bringing of the height to the surface, which like, again, these kinds
of movements are now not just like foreboding and, you know, the, the, the, the wrong kinds
of moves, you just have to see them as like the idealism, the idealist move as a movement
of the surface, a style of moving on the surface that, you know, maybe only really has its
problems or at least has its more identifiable problems when you think that's not what you're
doing that.
Yeah.
I mean, that's, that's exactly, but that's where, so the difference between say that the
Plato and the pre-Socratics is just, I don't know, like a dispositional difference.
It's not like, they're not different projects that going underneath or going above are both
ways of, of living on the surface.
So, I mean, it's, there's a simple way of saying that, which is just like, they're both
versions of Stoicism, which is, and if the Stoic question, if what's distinctive about
the Stoics is they say, how do you live well?
That's it.
That's their only question, right?
It's just, how do you live well?
Well, idealism and what, what, what's the equivalent of idealism for the depth model?
Well, like, you know, the subterranean, you know, so yeah, those are just versions of
ethics.
They're versions of living.
So Plato is an ethicist, even though he's an ethicist that believes that you have to know
what virtue is first, but he doesn't do, you have to know virtue first.
He has to.
That would be the content, that would be the content of Plato's argument, and we'd have
to take it to the movement, which is, like, the movement of his.
He doesn't, that's what I'm saying, he doesn't do, you have to know virtue first, he does an
inquiry into virtue.
Yeah.
Right?
That's what he does, and then from which he gets to be a sense of virtue.
Which always unravels into weird things.
Right, right.
All right.
So, so, so yeah, I mean, that's, to me, that's the, I mean, I've always thought that,
like, the real philosophical purchase of the concept of style is that in a, in a terrain
of ontological monism, it gives you a terminology for differentiating.
That's it.
So if you start with ontological, like, these things are all just practices in the world,
right?
That's all that they are.
Then we can distinguish between idealism, materialism, whatever, not because of their
correctness or because of their, you know, but just because they're, I mean, I think
We, we got this from the last, the last audio.
It's like, it's just the difference between whether you like country music or heavy metal.
Or whatever, or rap or whatever it is.
Like, that's it.
That's what the difference is.
Except for the differences between those styles really matter because those styles of movement
create entirely different worlds or create entirely different modes of love.
But so does country, so does country and heavy metal.
Yeah.
You know, like, this is, so when I say just, I don't mean it dismissively.
I mean it, I mean it's like, that's it.
That's the whole gambit is, do you listen to country or do you listen to heavy metal?
And there's no reason to listen to one or the other.
Right.
There is, or rather the reason to listen to one or the other is itself ska, right?
Like, it's another kind of you.
But understanding that point is key because if you're, the hypostasizing move is the problem,
right?
Where you're like, okay, country is, country is the right one to listen to.
Right.
Or this is country.
You can just say, this is country.
This is country.
Knowing what country is.
This is country, this is the, this country contains the truth about the world.
Like, where it's like, it's, it's an issue of interpretation and circulation more so than
like what this disposition does, you know, in itself.
Right.
I mean, it's like, that's, that's the issue with, that I'm taking with the post-humanist
bent, right?
It's like these people assume the correctness of it, even if they're not explicitly saying
that.
So it's like the dispositions get calcified, right?
And what you're arguing.
They do.
Yeah.
But, but calcification is just another mode of movement.
So, so you have to say, I mean, that's where to me, you really have to say, there's nothing
wrong with the calcification of dispositions.
It's like, they're just involved in a different project.
They're just, you know, like for instance, I want, what's that, what's that?
Bones have a function in the world.
Right.
Yeah.
Calcification is fine.
Like, you know, it's just, it's something to do on a Friday night.
But that's where, you know, like there are times where you want to listen to different
kinds of music.
And I just think, well, okay, so this is a time in Nathaniel Rivers or whoever else's
life where they want to listen to new materialism and, and they want to produce that music and
make that.
And, and that creates ecologies and that creates, you know, ways of thinking.
But I mean, to think of thinking that way is to me an extraordinarily liberating way of
thinking of it, where it's like, no, no, no, it's truly all, it's all sheer contingency.
Yes.
So that there is no reason or basis for one or the other, or every attempt at coming up
with a basis, or even the distinctions between what this is and what that is, is itself just
another, right?
It's just another song.
Not, again, not just, but it's, when I say just, I mean, it's on the same plane as them.
So when we look at and say, how is country different from heavy metal?
We say, well, look at the cultural differences and look at the racial implications and look at
all of those things, but all of that saying, look at, is just another song.
It's not a song that's in this position of gazing down upon them.
Yeah, it's a superiority.
Right, right.
Right.
Which again, it's, it's just in the sense that it's not correct or incorrect, but it's not
just insofar as they create.
It matters.
More or less hospitable worlds for, right.
But that's how you get, I mean, that's how you retrieve things like, like Nate wants
to, of like self-reflexivity, right?
You say like, look, it's not that self-reflexivity is a superior way of thinking.
It's just a song I like, right?
You know, that has implications that does interesting things, you know?
But you're, you're flattening of the, of this field, right?
Where it's, it's all dispositions or tastes or styles that would forbid, or at least it
would forbid, at least for me, a strict adherence to a team, right?
I mean, you can provisionally join a team, right?
And be like, I'm going to play around with post-humanism or idealism or whatever, but you're
rock and roll for a life.
Like, I don't, I feel like with that knowledge or with that supposition, you wouldn't just
simply, you wouldn't just dive in and say, I'm all in with the post-humanism.
But sure, it would be a hell of an experiment in life, right?
Right.
I mean, the, the, to me, there would be no, I feel like people join the priesthood for
that reason.
Or here's another way of saying it.
Here's another way of saying it, Nate.
One doesn't have to be conscious of the provisional status in order for it to be provisional.
Well, okay.
Okay.
Yeah.
Like, if I, whether or not I'm aware of it, it doesn't matter.
Because I, I think that, that, um, making it forbidden to calcify or making it forbidden
to say, like, I'm on team rock and roll for life.
Or even cool, like making it cool or uncool to be provisional or team.
But to, but to make that move would, to be, would necessarily to be, to take a position of
correctness.
Because it's all this way, therefore people shouldn't allow, like people should be more
free flowing.
But if you take it as a baseline that look, everything is flowing.
Calcification is a kind of flow.
And so are the rapids, you know, like, so was like the rapid movement of a waterfall, right?
Then it's not about it being moving or not being moving.
Or, you know, like, what if the, what, what if, you know, the move moving like a waterfall
was incompatible with, with this or that person's life, right?
What if that leads to them jumping off the waterfall?
All I'm saying is that if, if you're really attending to, I guess what you could call like
a symptomatology where every disposition is reflecting a style of life and none of them
is wrong.
They're all kind of reactions or assortments of sensibilities.
Well, we're saying, but, but just as an intervention, of course you can say things are wrong.
That's one of the dispositions, you know?
Right.
So, but that doesn't make them wrong.
That just means that that's okay.
But sorry, go ahead.
But I'm just saying, if you're actually attending to that constitutive dynamic, wouldn't you be
less likely to be all in on something?
Right?
No, because it would all be, wouldn't matter if you're being all in, half in, skipping across
the surface.
Right.
They would all.
It would make a difference.
Right.
Those would all be experimentations in life.
Right?
Like, hey.
Because, I mean, to me, you are focusing on the conscious awareness of all of these things.
And I'm sort of saying, like, it seems to me that the conscious awareness, it doesn't
really matter.
Like, that's, so one can be, for instance, a nomad and never know that you're a nomad.
Or one could be, like, firmly established in a position and think that one is entirely
open-minded, you know?
Yeah.
Yeah, that's true.
So that, that's a sense of which, like, you know, what we're saying, you know, thinking
is this necessarily provisional, for me, style or dispositional orientation.
And recognizing it as such is another disposition.
It's not the meta disposition that is diagnosing everything from above.
So even the, you know, that's where, so that's one of the moves that I have to make in a later
chapter for me of the Nietzschean symptomatology stuff on the values.
And the first one is, like, look, the, the diagnostician is not in a position of transcendence in
relationship to the patients, right?
That, that Nietzsche, that, that's why, for instance, for me, it's like, there are moments
in Nietzsche that I'm just like, ah, yeah, I'm not, I'm not on board with that, right?
Like, I'm just not on board with this, like, dismissiveness of the German culture and things,
and, and like, you know, fetishizing of a certain kind of war thing, like, but whatever, that
doesn't matter to me.
Like, and that's not a reason to dislike Nietzsche or, or, or, you know, it's just, I'm not
him.
That's, that's simple for me.
Or another way of using, just trying to mobilize the sense of transcendence that Deleuze is
using here is that the relationship of the self-reflexivity and the action is transcendent,
but on a flat plane where, you know, like there, like there is a transcendent link, transcendental
link, like a string that is attaching the, the self-reflective move laterally to the, I
can't go all in on something, right?
Which, or, but you can also imagine the self-reflective move being attached to, now I'm definitely going
to go all in on something just to see what it produces.
Well, frankly, like we talked about this, I think once during the Hegel stuff, but the
self-reflection thing usually is interpreted as neurosis, right?
Like once you get past a certain point of self-reflection, like two steps, like then
it becomes for most people paralyzing, right?
It's precisely because they think of it on that depth model that it becomes paralyzing.
If you have the lateral model, and I think I said this in one of the tapes, one of the
things is like, it's not, it's, I've never felt like self-reflection is paralyzing.
I always felt like it gives me new ideas of other things to do.
You know, so even, even though it's the sort of quote unquote meta move, but it's never
meta, it's never functionally meta, it's just sort of nominally meta.
My other question, just to jump back into the Deleuze a little bit.
So we're talking about, you know, so each disposition has its motivations, each philosophical disposition
has its motivations, has its context.
So therefore it can't necessarily be, you couldn't simply call it wrong or misguided, whatever.
So why does Deleuze in these series or in this book, why the attack on someone like Husserl then?
I mean, I understand the intervention and it makes sense logically, like why he would want
to make an intervention, but why the, the, the confrontation with him as opposed to, as
we're saying, like, uh, like a diagnosis where it's not as critical or as explicitly like dismissive.
I mean, my, my short answer to that is that the dismissive thing is a perfectly viable
move.
Like that you haven't, you haven't taken anything off the table by flat, flattening the thing
out.
And what he's attempting to do here, as I read it, he's trying to build a sense of this
transcendent, transcendent, eminent.
I mean, those words don't make sense anymore.
They, I mean, they really don't like, uh, uh, um, sense of sense, right.
And in doing so he's like, well, we could take this tool from here.
It encounters this problem there.
That's not a very good resolution to the problem.
I'm going to pull another thing from here.
Right.
So he's assembling different parts and assembling those parts.
And, and, but frankly, I, that's what I try to do in my work is like, I only take,
if I take the part, I don't need to explain why I'm not taking the whole, right?
Like I'm, I'm just taking the part.
Um, but I don't know.
I mean, there is also that sort of just differentiating function.
Yeah.
Right.
That is, that is powerful that there's a level at which it would be difficult to say anything
if you really committed to this, to the notion of the undifferentiated body without organs.
Right.
Like, um, and so to the extent to which we retain the part,
retain still some semblance of subjectivity, then we are still involved in that, in that
process of, of sifting and sorting and distinguishing, I guess.
Thank you.